hi this is a the other I present an
organization or leak a magical trustees
and also I have been recognized as one
of the global shapers representing the
Mumbai have quite a World Economic Forum
yesterday XP reach even the so far or
last two days we understand a lot of
things that's happening outside India
globally as such typically if I need to
talk about my generation some of the
problems that we offer are related to
every aspects of life beach employment
Bennett terrorism by the global
connectivity all these things are
happening and we definitely I put under
youth community as as such as a young
leader of myself I would like working on
pro formas one of such platforms which
helps us to raise our vows raise our
concerns and help us to contribute to
the economy of assets so it's been a
great to be fantastic event and I look
forward for many such bad economic
reforms conducting the events out there
in India I
you